fans of the Red Arrows will have spotted
they've been flying with fewer Jets this
season a sign of a troubled Squadron
after allegations of a toxic culture
prompted an inquiry that reportedly
resulted in two pilots being sacked
in the latest twist the RAF this week
confirmed the commander of the Red
Arrows has been suspended pending an
investigation into historic allegations
made against him husband it can now be
revealed two months earlier Wing
Commander David Montenegro spoke at the
head of the raf's annual leadership
conference hello I'm Wing Commander
David Montenegro known as Monty the
theme of the event was about the power
of trust
a video shared with Sky News shows the
officer being questioned on how the red
arrows are rebuilding trust following
the controversy and whether the raf's
disciplinary process can be trusted the
organization we live in nothing is swept
under the carpet the head of the royal
Air Force later applauds his officer's
contribution this wonderful Candor about
that you know what you know the the
events of this year you know at its
heart and you heard it from Monty
himself that was about you know the
Royal Air Force identifying toxic
behaviors in an organization and being
determined to do something about them
but Sky News understands the inclusion
of the Red Arrows was itself
controversial
talking to me anonymously an RAF Source
claimed that concerns were raised
internally about letting the Red Arrows
speak on trust at the leadership
conference because it could cause more
upset to the alleged victims and because
more allegations of bad behavior could
yet emerge The Source said the fact they
featured anyway was like a slap in the
face and raised questions about the
Judgment of the head of the Air Force
Air Chief Marshal sir Mike wigston
a former military officer who's raised
repeated concerns to the RAF about
alleged inappropriate behavior in the
Red Arrows expressed his surprise I'm
extremely shocked because there was no
way it was on that they would have been
in a position to
even hold any form for leadership and
how to deal with inappropriate behaviors
but a senior RAF Source defended the
move saying air Chief Marshall wigston
was part of the solution not the problem
The Source said the inclusion of the Red
Arrows was regarded as the RAF not
sweeping any failings under the carpet
and instead seeking to show how it's
addressed the issues
debraham Sky News